Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Mandy Vincent
Imaginez.
Nous sommes il y a 30 000 ans,
dans le sud-ouest de la France,
en Dordogne.
Et des hommes et des femmes
sont en train d’enterrer un des leurs.
À quoi ressemblent-ils ?
D’où viennent-ils ?
La personne qu’ils sont
en train d’enterrer
est-elle un de leurs ancêtres,
un de leurs parents ?
Sont-ils nos ancêtres ?
Depuis seulement
une petite dizaine d’années,
une nouvelle branche de la science
a révolutionné notre capacité
à répondre à toutes ces questions.
Et cette branche,
dont  j’ai fait mon métier,
c’est la paléogénétique.
La paléogénétique,
c’est l’étude de l’ADN,
du génome des êtres vivants
qui ne le sont plus, qui sont morts
mais morts il y a seulement
quelques années au plus tôt
et jusqu’à 1,6 million d’années
au plus tard.
1,6 million d’années,
c’est tout simplement le record du génome
le plus ancien jamais séquencé
et on l’a fait pour un mammouth
qui était en Sibérie.
Mais alors,
quelles sont les caractéristiques,
les spécificités de l’ADN ancien ?
Pourquoi ça fait seulement dix ans
qu’on le séquence ?
L’ADN, c’est cette molécule
en double hélice
qui porte des bases azotées,
ACTG,
et dont la séquence,
la succession dans un ordre précis,
porte notre information génétique.
L’information génétique,
c’est ce code qui va nous donner justement
des informations sur nos caractéristiques,
en tout cas certaines,
et peut-être un peu plus, on y reviendra.
Pour l’humain,
c’est 3 milliards de lettres
3 milliards de ACTG qui se succèdent.
Problème : pour l’ADN ancien,
cette molécule, cette belle double hélice,
est endommagée.
Elle est toute cassée
par le temps qui passe.
Concrètement, quand on meurt,
nos millions de cellules
sont rapidement détruites.
Or, dans chacune d’elles,
nous avons des millions
de molécules d’ADN,
donc des millions de molécules
d’ADN sont détruites
et il nous en reste
que très peu à séquencer.
On va donc perdre
une grande quantité d’informations.
Et ces quelques morceaux restants
vont être eux-mêmes saucissonnés
par toute une machinerie.
Et on va retrouver
des fragments très courts d’ADN,
plus du tout des longues doubles hélices.
Et ces fragments exposés à l’air libre,
à l’oxygène, aux bactéries,
vont être endommagés chimiquement.
Et ces dommages physiques se traduisent
par des modifications de la séquence,
des modifications de l’être,
ce qu’on appelle des mutations.
Or, des mutations, on en a des naturelles,
mais celles-ci sont fausses.
Donc, on va chercher
à les retrouver et à les éliminer.
Enfin, le dernier grand problème
qu'on a avec l'ADN ancien,
c'est la contamination.
Eh oui, quand on séquence
un génome ancien,
on commence par réduire en poudre
un petit morceau d'os.
Sauf que cet os, il a baigné
dans un bouillon d’ADN frais,
les bactéries du sol,
les micro-organismes,
et évidemment,
toute la chaîne d’humains
qui va manipuler cet os :
les archéologues, les conservateurs
et conservatrices de musée,
les techniciens
et techniciennes de laboratoire.
Et ça, malheureusement,
on n’a pas envie de le séquencer
parce que le séquençage
coûte encore un peu cher.
Alors, pour essayer de restreindre
au maximum cette contamination,
la première chose qu’on a faite,
c’est qu’on a transformé nos laboratoires
en salles blanches.
On a rendu nos consignes
de propreté drastiques,
on a tout nettoyé à la javel,
mis des lampes UV,
on s’est déguisés en cosmonautes.
Sauf que si on la minimise,
on ne la réduit pas complètement.
Et c’est là que les dommages,
ces changements, ces mutations fausses,
que je vous avais présentées
comme problématiques,
deviennent intéressantes
pour identifier l’ADN endogène,
l’ADN véritable contenu dans mon os.
Parce qu’en effet,
quand je séquence un humain ancien,
comment être sûre que j’ai sous les yeux
mon chasseur-cueilleur de Dordogne
et pas un des humains
qui a manipulé l’os ?
Puisqu’on connaît les dommages
provoqués par le temps,
si on les retrouve
sur notre molécule d’ADN,
on est capable d’authentifier,
d’identifier l’ADN ancien.
C’était un peu technique mais maintenant,
vous savez comment on retrouve
on séquence
et on authentifie l’ADN ancien.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’on en fait ?
La première chose
qui peut nous intéresser,
c’est de retrouver
certaines caractéristiques,
physiques et physiologiques,
de nos êtres vivants du passé.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le phénotype.
Par exemple, la couleur de vos yeux,
votre capacité à digérer
le lait sans problème,
votre groupe sanguin,
tout ça est partiellement encodé
dans votre génome.
Revenons en Dordogne,
il y a 30 000 ans,
à nos chasseurs-cueilleurs.
Que nous apprend
le crâne qu’on a retrouvé
de la personne
qui vient d’être enterrée ?
C’est une personne
de sexe génétique masculin,
à la peau extrêmement sombre
et aux yeux foncés.
Et ces caractéristiques,
la peau noire et les yeux foncés,
c’est celles de tous
les chasseurs-cueilleurs européens,
vivants il y a 30 000 ans.
Donc, globalement,
on s’intéresse au phénotype.
Sauf que, dans le génome humain,
constitué de 3 milliards de lettres,
seulement 2% de ces 3 milliards de lettres
codent pour le phénotype.
On a seulement 2% d’ADN codant.
Est-ce que vraiment on déploierait
tous ces trésors de technologie,
d’informatique, de laboratoire,
pour jeter 98% de la donnée
qu’on produit ?
Non parce que l’ADN,
étant héréditaire,
va nous donner des informations
sur l’histoire démographique
de la population
auquel l’individu appartient.
Et cette histoire,
comment est-ce qu’on la reconstruit ?
D’où elle vient ?
Pourquoi est-ce que l’ADN et son hérédité
nous permettent d’avoir accès
à cette histoire ?
Parce que chacun d’entre nous possédons
deux versions de notre génome :
un hérité de chacun de nos parents.
Et cette version héritée
de chacun de nos parents
est elle-même un mélange
du génome de leurs parents,
donc, de nos grands-parents.
Et le morceau de génome
hérité d’un de nos grands-parents
est lui-même un mélange du génome
de deux de nos arrière-grands-parents,
et ainsi de suite.
On peut dire que nous sommes toutes
et tous à l’échelle de notre génome,
une mosaïque du génome
de tous nos ancêtres.
Sauf que plus nos ancêtres
sont lointains et plus ils sont petits.
Et parfois, ils sont tellement lointains
que les morceaux de génome
ont presque disparu.
Et c'est là que l'ADN ancien
devient intéressant.
Parce qu’il nous permet d’accéder
à ces morceaux devenus si petits
qu’en fait, on ne peut plus
reconstituer l’histoire
juste avec les génomes modernes.
Prenons un petit exemple
et revenons en Dordogne.
Étudions le génome de ce chasseur-
cueilleur, l’entièreté de son génome,
et étudions nos génomes à nous,
les Français,
plus globalement les Européens.
Essayons de trouver les morceaux
de génome qu’on peut associer
au génome des chasseurs-cueilleurs.
Qu’est-ce qu’on voit ?
On a eu une sacrée surprise
parce que moins de 5% de notre génome
semble être hérité directement
des chasseurs-cueilleurs européens
d’il y a 30 000 ans.
Et 5%, c’est presque rien du tout.
Mais alors, que s’est-il passé ?
Que s’est-il passé
pour que les chasseurs-cueilleurs
qui vivaient en Europe il y a 30 000 ans
ne donnent presque aucun descendant ?
Pour répondre à cette question,
il faut s’intéresser à un des plus grands
changements culturels qu’a connu l’Europe,
l’arrivée de l’agriculture.
Ce grand changement a vu
sa compréhension bouleversée
par l’ADN ancien.
En effet, il y a 11 000 ans,
donc en -9000,
en Europe, on était toujours
des chasseurs-cueilleurs nomades,
alors que dans le croissant fertile,
les humains commençaient
à domestiquer les céréales,
domestiquer les animaux
et à se sédentariser.
Et c’est seulement 3 000 ans plus tard,
en -6000,
qu’on va voir arriver
ces pratiques en Europe,
que les archéologues vont découvrir
les premiers agriculteurs européens.
Et les archéologues vont observer
une certaine proximité entre les objets,
les poteries, les céréales
domestiquées en Europe
et celles qu’on va pouvoir retrouver
en Anatolie, en actuelle Turquie.
Et la question qu’ils se sont posé,
est-ce que l’agriculture en Europe
est arrivée par une diffusion culturelle ?
Que ce sont
les chasseurs-cueilleurs locaux,
les Européens qui ont copié
sur leurs voisins,
qui ont commencer à adopter
l’agriculture de proche en proche.
Ou est-ce que l’agriculture est arrivée
par diffusion démique ?
Diffusion démique,
ça veut dire avec une migration.
Est-ce que l’agriculture est arrivée
avec une grande migration
des agriculteurs anatoliens ?
Et ça, malheureusement, l’étude seule
des objets archéologiques ne suffit pas.
Parce qu’un objet,
ça voyage sans son humain.
Ça se transmet, ça se donne, ça s'échange.
L’ADN, en revanche,
ça voyage pas trop sans son humain.
Et donc, quand on a le génome
des premiers agriculteurs européens,
le génome des agriculteurs anatoliens
et le génome
des chasseurs-cueilleurs européens,
on peut essayer de comprendre
ce qu’il s’est passé.
De façon un peu schématique,
ce qu’on fait,
c’est qu’on va assigner une couleur,
la couleur bleue au génome
des chasseurs-cueilleurs européens
et la couleur jaune au génome
des agriculteurs anatoliens.
Et ensuite, on va scanner le génome
des premiers agriculteurs européens.
Et à chaque fois qu’on va retrouver
un petit morceau de ce génome
qui ressemble au génome
des chasseurs-cueilleurs européens,
on va le peindre en bleu.
Et à chaque fois qu’on va retrouver
un petit morceau du génome
de nos premiers
agriculteurs européens
qui ressemble au génome des Anatoliens,
on va le peindre en jaune.
En vérité, ça prend des heures
et des heures, des jours et des jours,
parfois même des semaines,
à faire ça de façon informatique.
Donc, sous vos yeux, le résultat :
nos premiers agriculteurs européens
sont presque jaunes,
presque complètement jaunes.
Leur génome est à plus de 90% hérité
des agriculteurs anatoliens.
Ce qui veut dire
que l’agriculture en Europe,
cette immense innovation,
est arrivée avec une vague de migration
en provenance d’Anatolie.
Vous voyez quand même qu’il y a
un peu de bleu, entre 5 et 10%.
Ça veut dire qu’en arrivant en Europe,
ces agriculteurs anatoliens
se sont métissés.
Ils se sont métissés
avec les populations locales,
les populations
chasseurs-cueilleurs européennes.
Et ça, cet exemple,
c’en est un parmi tous les événements
de migration et de métissage
qui ont été mis en évidence en Europe
et plus globalement dans le monde.
Ce qui me permet de dire aujourd’hui,
grâce à la paléogénétique,
que nous sommes tous
des descendants de migrants.
Et avec la paléogénétique,
on ne s’est pas arrêté aux humains.
On est allés plus loin,
on s’est intéressé aux animaux
qu’on a domestiqués,
par exemple les chevaux.
On a mis en évidence qu’on avait
domestiqué les chevaux il y a 4200 ans
dans les steppes en Ukraine
et en actuel Russie.
Et pourquoi ne pas aller aux pathogènes ?
On sait qu’on peut les retrouver
dans les racines de nos dents.
Et on a essayé de retrouver
l’origine de la peste noire
qui a ravagé l’Europe au Moyen Âge
et on l’a trouvée dans un petit lac
d’altitude en Asie centrale.
Bref, l’ADN ancien ouvre
des perspectives immenses.
Seulement à ce point,
j’aimerais ne pas vous laisser avec,
possiblement, deux fausses impressions.
La première serait
que l’ADN ancien peut tout.
Je viens de vous faire
une liste enthousiaste et emphatique
sur tout ce qu’on peut faire
avec l’ADN ancien
mais j’aimerais que l’on n’oublie pas
que déjà notre biologie,
ce n’est pas notre génome.
Nous sommes le fruit de l'interaction
entre notre génome et notre environnement.
L’épigénétique,
l’étude du microbiome, de toutes
les bactéries qui vivent avec nous,
sont autant de choses fondamentales
pour comprendre
notre fonctionnement biologique.
Et surtout, j’ai envie de dire,
notre humanité ne se résume pas
à notre biologie.
Nos interactions
avec le monde vivant non-humain,
nos mythes, nos religions,
nos langues, nos coutumes, nos lois
sont autant de choses que la génétique
et la paléogénétique ne peuvent atteindre.
Et c’est pour ça qu’en paléogénétique,
on travaille main dans la main
avec les sciences sociales
et les sciences humaines
comme l’archéologie,
l’anthropologie ou la linguistique.
La deuxième chose,
une deuxième fausse impression
que je n’aimerais pas vous laisser ce soir
serait celle que l’humanité
est facilement divisible
dans des groupes
génétiques bien distincts.
Après tout, je viens de dire
que j’arrivais à identifier
les populations chasseurs-cueilleurs,
les populations anatoliennes,
les populations européennes.
Et pourtant, toutes les études
de génétique et de paléogénétique
qui s’intéressent à l’humain
nous montrent une seule chose :
que nous sommes une espèce
extrêmement homogène
et qu’il est très difficile
de nous séparer
dans des groupes génétiquement distincts,
que nous formons tous de beaux gradients.
Avec 0,1% de différence
entre deux humains pris au hasard,
nous sommes même l’espèce animale
la plus homogène qui soit,
alors même que nous avons
conquis tous les continents.
Et cette incroyable homogénéité,
cette ressemblance,
tout simplement impressionnante
entre chacun et chacune d’entre nous,
s’explique d’abord parce qu’on vient
de petites populations d’Homo sapiens,
avec une diversité réduite
à notre origine,
mais notre homogénéité s’explique surtout
parce que, partout où il a été,
l’humain s’est toujours métissé.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)